so family day out but I'm curious is
this the Twins Red Carpet debut it's it
is the red carpet debut oh my gosh
okay
um yeah this is we didn't realize there
was gonna be a red carpet but here we
are of course we would have dressed a
little nicer we're in our rock and roll
gear today
oh yeah he does like a microphone I have
to say yeah these kids just seeing them
makes me so happy the two of you in your
beautiful relationship what has been the
wildest parenting moment so far oh my
gosh there's too many to even like I
mean just flying with them yeah flying
is high stress
catastrophes no just a few meltdowns but
you know everyone's been very nice not
as bad but yeah we're gonna fly as least
as possible with them that's for sure
well eager for a job at ET I love it
I just want to congratulate you your
your podcast has exploded in the most
beautiful way possible everyone is
talking about it you and AJ kind of you
know set the internet on fire yeah AJ
doesn't hold back which is great in sync
yes Backstreet Boys I've heard of them
stadium tour yes 2024 2024. well you
know who you have to convince I know I
know what is it gonna take to get this
BSB in-sync reunion tour happening
there's a lot of things that need to
happen uh first all the guys have to
agree
um so yeah working on that I mean it's
been working we've been working on it
for 20 years so uh we'll see if it ever
uh pans out but you know we're having a
good time on the podcast yeah I've
already kind of come out guns blazing
with some amazing guests who can you
tease is coming up next it's funny
because we don't even know who's coming
up until the week like five days before
we do it it's just whoever's available
at the time but there's so many iconic
Teen Idols and boy banders out there so
we're gonna have plenty of guests for
the next two years so we'll have to
figure out what to do after we kind of
exhaust all of that okay look I know
you've spoken very glowingly of your
girl Brittany over the years is she
someone that you want to get on the
podcast or are you kind of letting her
do her own thing right now I mean she is
a Teen Idol so she is more than welcome
to be on uh so yeah I mean I think her
stories I mean look she had the a front
row seat to all of the boy band
craziness so uh yeah she would she would
definitely have some good stories you
were incredible at that recent Nick
Carter tribute event and it was so
awesome to see LFO 98 Degrees O Town in
sync Backstreet has the idea ever been
floated to do a super group and take
that gig out on the road I think that's
definitely been floated around many many
times uh I don't know if I would ever do
it just because now these two things are
really keeping us very busy so I don't
know if the road is for me anytime soon
okay so then it goes back to the
Backstreet in sync tour situation what
would you make a special exception for
that I mean I would as long as they
would be able to go with us but yeah
sure why not I'm so happy for the two of
you you're coming up on a decade of
Mayor marriage I'm curious what has been
the best moment and what has been the
best lesson well this is the best moment
right here having these two kids yeah
um but yeah I mean I think like everyone
says communication is key and I think
the first two years we were together we
didn't know how to communicate because
we were very opposite in that way
um I talk about everything he holds
everything in and now we're able to kind
of swap a little bit and yeah get it out
of each other you want to do a big epic
10-year celebration situation I mean
maybe I don't know we'll see I don't
want to give a bad luck I feel like on
all those like housewife shows they
always do a big 10-year or something and
then they get divorced
was so fun I would I would love to
relive that and actually remember it
because it just flew by so quickly
take every moment and cherish it thank
you both so much
[Music]